you have an Oscar nomination and the
show how is this run been for you and
what does it mean to you you know it
really feels Like A lot's happening all
at once it feels like motherhood Oscar
Super Bowl
there's no need for Rihanna to send out
an SOS as she gears up for her apple
music Super Bowl halftime performance
because her Beau ASAP Rocky is right by
her side I'm still pinching myself
really I'm grateful I'm grateful a
source tells E.T the rapper and their
son who was born last May plan to be
there during her big day Rocky's been
very supportive throughout the
preparation and really been stepping up
his parenting game while Rihanna has
been busy with rehearsals what did I
just get myself into because the Super
Bowl is one of the biggest stages in the
world but riri's got it handled our
source says she's been preparing for
months and wants it to be the most
iconic performance quote there will be
lots of color and messaging and she
wants it to be memorable it is a huge
deal to her and she is taking it very
seriously I want to incorporate
a lot of culture I want to incorporate
different aspects of
entertainment and things that I just
enjoy
and bring it to the stage but the
biggest challenge rerease faced what to
perform that was the hardest hardest
part
um
deciding how to
maximize 13 minutes
but also
celebrate that's what the show is going
to be it's going to be a celebration of
my catalog in in the best way that we
could have put it together and you're
trying to cram
17 years of work into 13 minutes so it's
it's difficult Rihanna has a big
performance
yeah so would you give her any advice
I don't know that there's any much any
if I see she she's got so many hits that
she all she's got to do is cough
because she's she's just got so much so
much great music and we're just gonna
all be there to celebrate and celebrate
her Babyface is performing America the
Beautiful ahead of the big game and he's
so ready for Riri show to follow our
source says she's super excited to get
back out there and perform since having
her son plus it's been seven years since
Rihanna's toured or released an album
you're still gonna get music from me as
for what's been Rihanna's biggest
inspiration her baby boy quote being a
mother has changed her entire
perspective on work and life in general
and her son has given her even more
meaning to her music and she's so
excited to Showcase that in her
performance
foreign